all right well welcome everyone my name
is Tony lodgeowitz I'm a faculty member
over at the Yale School of the
environment where I direct the Yale
program on climate change communication
uh here we're going to be hearing about
uh this particular talk called
navigating the future harnessing
data-driven insights on climate Mobility
to build a common agenda uh very pleased
to welcome to Yale to friends of mine
who I was just with last week at climate
week in New York doing a really big and
exciting and really important effort to
look at climate migration climate Force
displacement of peoples and how do we
begin to think proactively about
managing what is likely to be many
millions of people being forced to move
either temporarily or permanently so um
unfortunately the reality of climate
change is all too evident over the
certainly this past summer with all-time
record global temperatures but this has
been happening now for many many years
for those that have been paying
attention and uh it's only getting more
intense so this is an incredibly time
appropriate conversation to be having
and I'm just super excited to welcome
both of them to Yale to help brief us
about some of the work they've been
doing
here they're going to unpack the efforts
of the global Center for climate
Mobility which they have spearheaded to
further climate Mobility knowledge and
solutions they will underscore the
importance of data modeling and
stakeholder engagement to support
proactive adaption strategies for
communities confronting the climate
crisis
and so they're really going to be
presenting this larger approach of the
gccm anticipate plan and transform and
discuss the findings and recommendations
of their Africa climate Mobility
initiative which is where they've
started as well as ongoing work to
expand this in Latin America and the
Caribbean so I'll let them describe the
project in more detail but let me
quickly introduce them David Lundberg
who serves as the senior advisor for
Youth and Outreach at the global Center
for climate Mobility where he supports
the Africa climate Mobility initiative
the greater Caribbean climate Mobility
initiative and the rising Nations
initiative so you can see this is now
very popular to work as well as the
development of the gccm solutions lab he
previously worked at NGO shift 7 and the
UN non-governmental liaison service he
also served as an advisor to the federal
foreign office of Germany and a
consultant to unicef's office of
innovation he holds a master's in
international affairs from Columbia
University School of International and
public affairs and Sarah and rosengarder
currently served as the lead for
knowledge and practice of the global
Center for climate Mobility where she
oversees the efforts of the Africa
climate Mobility initiative and the
greater Caribbean climate Mobility
initiative as well as the development of
gccm's Global Knowledge Hub with the
Columbia University climate School
she's a fellow at The zolberg Institute
for migration and Mobility at the new
school and an adjunct lecturer at
Columbia University School of
International and public affairs she
previously held advisory roles with
several foundations universities and the
UN Secretary General on migration Peter
Sutherland focusing on improving
cooperation on and the governance of
international migration she holds
degrees in political science from the
Free University of Berlin and Sciences
Poe in Paris so with that please join me
in welcoming both to Yale
[Applause]
thanks Tony thanks Teresa thanks to
everybody for coming everybody in the
room everybody online very excited to be
here thanks to MacMillan Center for
hosting us I'm David and I'm Sarah thank
you and yeah shall we hit it off yeah
see if we can get to work
so this is what we're going to talk
about today so we'll first we'll do a
little introduction of who we are and
the global Center for climate Mobility
gccm so if you hear gccm we come from
the UN we use a lot of acronyms sorry in
advance that's how it's going to be so
I'm also going to talk about the
regional kind of built initiatives and
how sort of the overall model is set up
of how we're working and then Sarah will
go into more depth and talk about the
African kind of Mobility initiative also
referred to as ACMI so if somebody here
HDMI that's it and then we have the
great Caribbean client built initiative
gccmi to make it even harder
um yeah sorry it's going to talk about
that as well and then we'll have q a at
the end if there are any burning
questions throw up a hand we're easy
going we'll get to it and we can say oh
we'll come back to that or we'll take it
right away so we'll try to make this as
interactive as and fun as possible
you're very smart people here so I'm
sure you'll have a lot of questions and
don't hold me too long so you forget
them
so looking at our goals of our
organization we have three three things
that we try to mention this anticipate
plan and transform
so the anticipatory part is to focus on
all the early action and being out early
and to be able to understand what is
going to happen when it comes to climate
forced migration and displacement also
to referred to as time Mobility
then based on that information that we
get through the knowledge work that we
do we then try to convene policy makers
and stakeholders in different convenings
to plan for what's ahead
with that information and with those
coalitions then looking at how we can
guide adaptation work and also work with
the development planning and Investments
to address this in in climate Mobility
hotspots we'll come back to this notion
of hot spots and and what that means but
that's something that you will hear
quite a lot in this presentation
so how do we do this when we're trying
to address these calls we build
knowledge
the advanced policy and we accelerate
diplomacy and enable practice big words
but we try to live up to them we try to
do
various things within them Sarah as you
heard in in the interaction from Tony is
leading our knowledge work that really
focus on how the Frontline communities
are going to be affected during the
climate crisis and what that's going to
do for Mobility
based on that information we're then
trying to advance coalitions uh when it
when it comes to policy to take action
achieve Justice and also then advance in
these different fields that you see the
outline peace Building Development Etc
in the policy area
how this is done as well is through
accelerating diplomacy we have come from
the UN after all and we work in that
space so we have something to do with
diplomacy uh this is a picture from last
week actually both these pictures off
from last week but that's John Kerry and
this is the president of the G1 general
assembly at our sea level rise Summit
that we had last Thursday so see how can
we Foster narratives and Advance climate
mobility in the international
diplomatic space
and also back to Sarah when it comes to
practice how do we can can we Foster
community of practice around the world
that works on these topics we'll come
back to this a bit more as well when we
look at the different initiatives and
what we do in the different regions
so looking at the regional models that
we are using for these different
initiatives
so we're working towards people-centered
climate action
we can talk about mitigation we can talk
about different things that we need to
do because of to tackle the climate
crisis but we're also trying to bring
back the people into this discussion and
that's Central when you talk about
mobility and migration
so it is a joint undertaking and that's
something we say we're un this and that
but we also work with the World Bank and
Regional organizations it's always
anchored Regional organization in Africa
it's African Union in the great
Caribbean Association for Caribbean
States
so
tying back into these things that we
discussed discussed in the previous
slides on the approach we are producing
an evidence-based approach
we're also trying to generate political
momentum through this Coalition building
and agendas
and then that hopefully leads to action
that is people-centered and takes people
into account when we're trying to tackle
the climate crisis and when we try to
address migration across these regions
and I should say that we work across
these different you see these different
terms here climate action migration
displacement and sustainable development
three different agendas that operate on
under the in the International Space
that we're all trying to bind together
in in these initiatives
so how are we trying to do this is that
we're doing uh modeling of people and
population modeling and migration
modeling of how people are foreseen to
be moving the future based on different
different data sets crop yield water
availability
migration patterns other things that are
have to do with with climate change and
how this can affect people I'm not going
to go into rcps ssps there's beautiful
information online and Sarah might
mention a little bit about that but
they're basically how you set up these
different scenarios for the future in
terms of development and also in terms
of emissions
and yeah we do this up until 2050 to get
a pretty good picture down to to to Red
granular granular information on how
that will look in the different regions
after 2050.
we also coupled this with looking at
here it comes again hotspots we'll go
into these hotspots to conduct
qualitative research through partners
and and and people in our Network so
we're looking at for example here are
the regions in Africa that we've gone to
and done this you'll see Lagos you see
Guana you see beta Etc but we've done
focus groups and interviews to get a
better understanding of what's behind
these numbers that we see in in the
modeling work
so both seeing what's happening right
now but also seeing people's outlooks
for the future which I will talk more
about
then this is leads to consultations so
we conducted a consultation process in
Africa and we will do one degree
Caribbean as well the one in Africa had
over 700 entities participating in
different formats everything from
community members Academia policy makers
ngos I think we even had private sector
in some of them so we covered quite a
lot of stakeholder groups in there
um so this also leads to the creation of
an agenda for Action we will get back
which we will get back to
but it basically is this bridge between
the modeling data the information from
the from the from the qualitative work
and how we can analyze that and turn it
into something that's actionable
we also have stakeholder forums and
engage with different constituencies I
as you heard in the introduction work
particularly with youth and there we
have especially since that's the most
advanced advanced initiative a very
vibrant African youth Network
that is working across different parts
of of our of our of our initiatives but
I would definitely like to mention that
they have four cops last year to develop
the Africa climbability climate Mobility
youth declaration with the African Union
youth Envoy and various youth groups
that they presented uh and and they're
trying to find different ways to how to
take rnl our data and our research and
bring it out into what's actionable from
youth perspective
so looking at the modeling and the
research and the consultations what that
leads to uh Sarah was one of the lead
authors so she's going to talk more
about how this was done but it led to uh
the African shifts report and the agenda
fraction the report is online there's a
link there you can find laughter so I
will also go through the details I'll
not speak a lot about it but that is
basically taking all that information
together and putting out in a format
that hopefully is digestible and not
your usual un report and also the agenda
for Action that are the actions that we
are looking to hopefully drive up until
2030.
and here the for Africa I should say
that this is something that's done for
all the regions but this might look
different for the great Caribbean for
Africa this was the agenda that was
Advanced or put forward in this context
is focus on our plan and power and
transform
and we have this different eight
different actions that touches upon
different parts of what we think needs
to be done or not what we think needs to
be done but people in this in these
consultations came forward with as
actionable things that we need to see
leading up to 2030 when it comes to
climate mobility in Africa
also want to mention this we try to put
all this information on a digital
platform as well we not only a strive we
actually did it and it's it it is a more
digestible way to communicate the
stories and storytelling is an important
part on how to address this uh and make
this comprehensible because there is
modeling going up until 2050 but that's
not always easy to for to understand
what that means for people so
we have interviews we have videos we
have different stories we have the data
the data is available there you can go
and play with this yourself to different
data sets and see how Africa is will be
affected according to the modeling
everything is available online and you
can go and check it out there
I want to wrap up my part here by
talking a little bit about how we bring
this ecosystem together and how we're
trying to advance the coalitions so this
is from cop last year where we had the
first climate Mobility Pavilion trying
to bring the climate Mobility discussion
into the cough space which has not been
done before there have been I don't want
to discredit there are certain actors
that of course have operated in the
climate conference space but it's not
been a dedicated Pavilion so trying to
bring the ecosystem together we put this
polygium together and had over 70 events
over 10 days with everything from heads
of state to to community activists
participating in coming together
also last week as Tony mentioned we had
a chance to meet Tony and Tony was on
one of the panels we had a client who
builty Summit during the on the margins
of the U.N General Assembly
bringing together same sort of
variation of stakeholders you see mayor
rivon from Sierra Leone from Freetown
you see the president of Guatemala in
the middle you see the the head of the
Africa the association for Caribbean
States uh Rodolfo sabank standing middle
as well as well as various es un
entities
an academic as well from another
institution we don't have to talk about
which institution but he's hiding up in
the corner
um hopefully Yale next time
um and with that we're moving into the
work that we've done in Africa maybe
just to
um
dovetail with where David ended and kind
of you know connect the dots a little
bit so that's this initiative has
Ambitions really on three different
levels
we started at the regional level but
we're working across different regions
to connect efforts at the global level
and at the same time as I'll discuss a
little further going down from the
regional level down to the National and
Community level so we're trying to
really connect efforts across these
different levels of governance and as
David already described also working
across different sectors of policy
making as well as across different
stakeholders so it's really kind of a
pretty intricate puzzle that we're
trying to solve and it's I think on the
one hand driven by the urgency of the
climate crisis as Tony mentioned but I
think it's also really driven by our
analysis of the current geopolitical
environment and the need to elevate the
voices of the global majority in what is
the climate conversation so as David
mentioned we have
a discourse on climate that's driven by
mitigation and decarbonization which is
important but for the majority of people
in the world that are most affected by
the climate crisis there's very little
to decarbonize in their lives and so how
do we Elevate their concerns in the
global conversation that is very much
what drives kind of our work
um
for the Africa climate abilities I
actually don't have a clicker so I will
have to ask you to click forward I'll go
a bit through our findings David has
explained the process so we did modeling
we did field research we did
consultations we put together a report
these are some of our findings and I
work you walk you through the substance
now and then we'll come back to more of
the process conversation
um this is not our finding this is from
the ipcc but I think it's fairly
um common knowledge we have this
discrepancy between uh Africa's
greenhouse gas emissions what I just
mentioned there are very few countries
that have you know significant work to
do on decarbonization in Africa
but when we look at the climate risk
it's very high for much of the continent
so you have very little contribution to
the problem but very high exposure to
and vulnerability to the problem
we also looked at and this is thanks to
research done by our colleague Dr Nick
Simpson who was a co-author of the
report
we also looked at what is the level of
climate change literacy across the
continent
um
and they have they work this is based on
afro barometer data and they have looked
at
at the sub-national level different
districts what's the level of climate
change literacy and found very high
discrepancies within countries and
across countries
and I think it dovetails with some of
the findings that you presented Tony
last week which is that you still have
quite low levels of climate change
knowledge in many parts of the continent
um generally the awareness is higher in
cities and urban areas it's lower in
rural areas and more remote kind of
Border regions
um
but that doesn't necessarily always
dovetail with people's lived experiences
as we'll see from our own field research
but basically if we're just going with
the kind of have people heard of climate
change do they know what the impacts
might be on their livelihoods the rates
are quite low especially in some of the
most vulnerable areas
so this is based on the both
quantitative and qualitative data
collections so we did surveys but also
interviews and this was done by the
mixed migration Center for us
in those seven locations David showed a
map with seven locations across the
continent this is where this was done we
had a mix of rural urban areas Coastal
different types of climate impacts that
were already occurring some areas
affected by drought others experiencing
Cyclones sea level rise different types
of climate impacts
um and what we found across those seven
locations was that overall the majority
of people very much notice climate
disruptions in their lives like they're
aware that this is happening
but it's not uh something that they
um consider or the most of them do not
consider to move because of those
disruptions so for a majority more than
50 percent they say yeah you know we see
stuff is happening we take certain
measures to try to adapt but moving is
not necessarily one that we would want
to take or are considering taking you
have almost a quarter though
that say yeah we would maybe move if we
had the resources to do so so the
constraint on moving has often has to do
with the resources that people have
available or their own perception of
those resources
foreign
if we look at reasons for moving you can
see and this is not surprising I think
from the literature but it confirms a
lot of existing research that very much
climate change interacts with other
factors that make people want to move
consider moving and here we looked at
economic impacts so livelihood factors
most of the time and you see that in
most of the cases it's more livelihood
or income related reasons that would
make people consider moving or want to
move
the outliers are really in areas where
you had fairly recent extreme events
like Bearer for example which was hit by
Cyclone I think it's covered here but um
had a very fairly high percentage of
people saying yes we want to move
similarly chickwawa and malavi which was
like hit by different impacts
alternating between flooding and drought
and so where people were kind of at a
point where they were like okay we're
ready to move because of this because
it's just been too much with pledge but
generally for example in a Lagos
or Alexandria where people had some
perception of climate impacts it was
mostly about like living conditions how
can we move to a better neighborhood but
it was less driven by the climate Factor
um
this is the gender breakdown and what we
found
um across locations mostly not it's not
always true but mostly women were more
reluctant to move than men so they had
less intentions to move
um
and if you go to the next slide
this is by age group we found that the
young people were those most prone to
wanting to move so the majority of young
people still said I'm not considering
moving
but they were the largest age group that
were had actually plans to move like
um
were more actively engaged in
in making those plans
next slide
so then we go to the quantitative work
and this is based on the modeling that
they would briefly presented we did two
types of modeling we looked at
cross-border migration
and we looked at internal movements and
we did not manage to do both within the
same model so we had two separate models
[Music]
um
this is the findings for the
cross-border movement and this was a
pilot I would say so um the methodology
was quite new
um
and the results are
I think fairly
um
significant but also
um you know in in the context of the
overall population development in Africa
not overwhelming so you have
a fairly small percentage of overall
projected movement being related to
climate change right like this is the
total projection of cross-border
migrants that could be moving by 2050
and then within that the climate related
movement is a fairly small percentage
um
and the same is true
um in the in the more optim sorry this
is the
more optimistic scenario in terms of
climate impacts and this is the more
pessimistic scenario so you also see
that actually the um the impacts of
climate change have a more
reducing impact on cross-border Mobility
which makes sense again if we look at
the need for people to have resources to
move
next slide
then we have internal movements of
people moving within countries and that
is
um
a more significant amount of people
projected to be moving
anywhere between
46 to 113 million so
if we stay within the scenarios the most
likely uh
outcome under a kind of
High emissions future is around 88
million people four percent of the
African population moving within their
countries
but it could go up to 113 a more
optimistic scenario when it comes to
development and climate emissions has
sees a lower range of internal Mobility
and this is the hot spots analysis so
one thing is to try to put numbers on
the movement I think the more important
maybe potential of this analysis lies
with understanding the geographic
distribution
of where is those where are those
movements likely to happen so what this
map shows are areas that are likely to
be origins or destinations respectively
of movements
um and you see that they're quite
concentrated in the Sahel belt
um
on the coasts and then also on some of
the Border regions like like Victoria
for example you have the Border region
between Ethiopia Sudan Eritrea
um so this this is what we'll be using
going forward working with governments
at the more National sub sub-regional
and local level this is hot Sports
analysis
so this is the next step after we've
done the Continental level analysis and
had kind of have presented our results
and agenda for Action we're now working
with individual countries
sub-regional organizations and cities to
take these hot spots analysis
down to the country local sub-regional
level
to help them start making sense of
prospective
population shifts within their territory
and how our analysis cross-references
with data that they may be having at the
local and National level so we're trying
to integrate different sources of data
and knowledge at the national level at
the local level
with the view to supporting planning
policy development at that level of
intervention and eventually drive
towards projects and programming in
those hot spots areas
um
so this first the first country where
we're doing this is Uganda
this is the steps of the process and it
mirrors very much the kind of process
we've gone through at the regional level
so we start with this analysis of
different data and research bringing
together our modeling data with other
sources of data and information
we go through a phase of consultations
now within the country
and then want to develop what we call a
blueprint this could I think take
different forms depending on the country
context but the ultimate goal is to
influence both adaptation and
development planning that's happening at
the country level with this information
about like where are the areas the
geographies but also the groups of
people and the sectors of your economy
that you should be particularly
concerned about when it comes to people
moving
this is from the climate Mobility
profile we have pulled together for
Uganda
starting with climate information
what are the trends in the country
next slide
um
what are the hazards and and how are
people affected by them so for Uganda
you see different types of Hazards
affecting you don't see this here but
they're affecting different parts of the
country
um next slide then again we're looking
at the climate literacy rates based on
the data we had we used also for the
Continental level analysis
um so understanding different levels of
climate literacy across the country
and then we are drawing on our own data
to look at what's the situation for
Uganda so how will cross-border flows
for Uganda look like
um over the next
30 years here you can see
but most much more movement projected to
go out of the country than coming into
the country
um
next slide
internal projections this is what we saw
for the Continental level here in Uganda
the high point is 5.1 million
potential internally displaced people or
people moving
and this is the hot spots map for Uganda
um
one is the kind of most likely where
different scenarios of the modeling have
the highest level of agreement this is
how you get to this map
[Music]
um
and this map is the actual numbers of
people projected to move from one part
of the country to another part of the
country
and this those pixels are roughly for
four to five square kilometers
um so that's the resolution
then we look at what are existing
factors of vulnerability such as the
climate literacy rates but also where
for example existing refugee camps or
Refugee populations
[Music]
um so looking at them as a group of
concern
but also looking at things like poverty
levels and and um
marginalization
[Music]
next slide and this is our analysis by
cities so we have different ways of
looking at the data for the Continental
level we did a geographic
regions analysis so we looked at urban
areas we looked at rural areas coastal
areas separately and we're doing the
same for at the country level so this is
the city level analysis which are the
cities that will be growing because
there's overall urbanization and
population growth going on but where
climate Mobility could be
leading to a dent in that growth so
basically you have cities that are
growing but because of climate impacts
there are some people forecast to leave
predicted to leave that city which kind
of suggests that overall conditions in
the city could become more hazardous
also for people who are not leaving
and then you have cities that are
projected to grow due to climate
Mobility so where the city is
where climate Mobility is actually
contributing meaningfully to the growth
of the city and you see kind of like
this flip side here in Uganda
um
so what are we doing next with this
analysis
um
we're planning to have consultations
engagement with stakeholders across
Uganda so going to different parts of
the country to share our initial
findings but to understand what are the
local realities and how how does this
inter intersect with what's going on how
people are perceiving climate impacts
and the movement of people the
implications that already resolved at
the moment
with a view to
co-developing recommendations for Action
looking at what could be pilot
interventions in areas that are
particularly impacted
and then also seeing at how do we get to
a level of granularity that could
actually support decision making like if
you wanted to decide to put water
infrastructure in a certain place or to
build more housing in a certain place
the modeling that we have is not
sufficiently detailed
and you see it has these large
uncertainty intervals so you know if we
wouldn't be like yeah you should really
put your housing here because our model
says you know this so the idea is also
like how do we start based on more
locally collected data to build some
decision support tools which would be
more agent-based models so like actually
understanding like what are the local
Dynamics and how do we develop support
tools that can
um that can actually inform these kinds
of
infrastructure investment decisions
policy
um uh making
add a more local and granular level
um
yep
and now we kind of like take a step back
up so in Africa we've kind of gone from
the Continental down to the country and
local
in the greater Caribbean we're starting
where we started in Africa two years ago
um
um with an effort at kind of mobilizing
interests and political buy-in for the
initiative which was officially launched
last year
so we've been holding a number of events
um just socializing this idea in this
initiative with governments in the
region
um
we have started modeling and we're using
a different approach this time so
the model that we use for Africa is
called a gravity model it's mainly
focused on kind of geographic
assumptions about how people are
distributed in space and then when
climate impacts kind of are layered in
how does that affect the attractiveness
attractiveness of places vis-a-vis each
other
this is an econometric model we're using
this time so it looks much more at how
climate impacts will affect different
sectors of the economy and labor
productivity in different sectors of the
economy and how that will affect
people's decisions to go to certain
areas or move out of other areas
so we're expecting to have
quite different types of results it will
still give us an idea of again like what
are hot spots areas but it will be much
more tied to what is the economic impact
of climate change and how is this
affecting people's decisions to move
and this is our roadmap we're working
towards cop 29 so that means end of 2024
to basically arrive what at what David
laid out the process of
first doing the research then doing the
consultations having a report having
stories bringing it all to cop and then
again like in that region as well
starting to work with individual
Champion countries to look at what does
this mean for you how do we bring this
down to the local level
um while at the same time continuing to
build that momental momentum in global
policy forum
so that was a lot
but now the floor is yours
[Applause]
questions
um I just have a quick question going
back to her point on using different
models for different regions would you
mind explain a little bit more of why
you decide your team decided to use the
gravity-based model for Africa and then
the more sectorial economic economic
based approach for cabins and maybe
maybe different kinds of models to use
for other regions
yeah
should I go ahead
um
the main reason was that for the gravity
model to work well you basically need
some
territory to move people around on and
with a lot of the small islands in the
Caribbean it's very difficult like the
model is struggling to basically project
movements if the if the territory is
very small
um and so they I think the search for
different alternative model led us to
this econometric model we had a workshop
with all kinds of different modelers
presenting different approaches that
they are currently pursuing what we're
looking for I think is always an
approach that is globally applicable
which limits options so we're trying to
find models that can work
across different regions ultimately so
we
um
I think are looking yeah to to as much
as possible get inputs in terms of the
data that are region specific but have a
model that can be applied across
different contexts
um
yeah but the main reason was that we
were trying to look at these small
island States and the gravity model at
according to our colleagues who are
doing the modeling is not so good at
looking at population redistribution in
these very small territories
more about the decision support tools
that sort of are in need now and how
they interplay with the current models
that you have and like what you would
hope that they would answer
yeah so I think um
again like our model gives kind of an
indication of okay these are areas that
you should be concerned about or look at
for Action
um but then when it comes to actually
guiding decisions on
you know again putting in place specific
infrastructure or maybe
expanding social protection programs or
what have you like actually kind of a
better understanding of
um well how many people when are they
going to move
um based on which triggers or thresholds
um you need something that is more
informed by what's actually really going
on in the country because what we know
is that the model that we have is
informed by global climate models that
often struggle to represent what's
happening in Africa because there's not
so much data collection and data
available
so you have often assumptions being made
also on the migration side about like
well let's you know use Ghana and expand
the data from Ghana across these other
five countries for which we don't have
data that kind of thing
which then if you're actually in one of
those other five countries is not so
helpful right like you don't really your
model is not informed by the data that
actually is reflecting the local reality
and so if you want something that can
actually support decisions on like
should we build a sea wall here or put
water pipes there or build housing here
you need something that reflects more
like actual Dynamics in the country and
you have
companies and consultancies that do that
kind of work
so we're trying to see you know once we
have
our more broader analysis of like okay
you know we know that these coastal
areas you should be concerned about how
do we bring that expertise to our
government Partners to then say okay
let's do the more granular analysis of
you know you might want to put this
piece of infrastructure in this way or
yeah
so to actually kind of like get started
on specific projects
so thank you both
aside from the
suggestions or the action that the
results of these models might you know
point out for the countries that will
experience
you know the harshest effects of the
climate crisis have you I guess what
have you found in terms of
showing this data to the countries that
are the biggest causes and how do you
feel as if
this kind of a finding or these kinds of
reports are moving the needle
politically or is it just another drop
in the ocean
it's a good question I mean I think the
main concern usually for countries in
the global North if you will is is more
around like who's coming to us right
like do you have figures for Africans
moving to Europe or Latin Americans
moving to the US
um
I think what we are trying to convey is
the message that you know most people
are moving close to home which is
already true but will most likely be
true in the future too from what we know
and what we observe so yes there will be
also South North movements but the
majority of movement is happening
close to home and people are not all you
know clamoring to leave
um and so really what we're trying to I
think pinpoint is a the need for scaling
up adaptation investment which is not a
new message but to reinforce that point
but then also to guide that investment
right like to say if you're trying to
again like in a more anticipatory
fashion not just kind of try to get on
top of disasters and and
um
uh do recovery on a Perpetual basis but
to try to look ahead and see how can we
get ahead of the curve in certain
um instances and say okay this is where
people are likely to move if we can put
investment here now you know then the
city does not have to become overwhelmed
with informal settlements we have living
conditions are terrible you can start
putting infrastructure in place now
um you can start you know thinking about
economic sectors where people could find
jobs now
so that is a little bit the logic on
what we're hoping to achieve is
basically a get to a clear message
around like you know get out of your
navel gazing if you will you know the
problems are are acute and they're
they're for people already real now
and then you know start planning ahead
and supporting countries
um before before the situation becomes a
crisis
I'm thinking back in the African model
and the maps that you had of the places
where people would be fleeing from and
where they would be going to so the red
versus the Green locations what
variables are associated or seem to be
predictive of either of those two
locations where people will be moving
from or moving to
yeah so the um the model
generally assumes that people will be
drawn to more densely populated areas so
it has kind of like a bias towards
urbanization assuming that people will
want to be where there's more amenities
and that those places are more
attractive
but then the basically the what it does
is like it looks at a future where you
have just development happening and
where would people be in terms of
population distribution and then it
Compares that to a scenario where you
have climate impacts happening and the
climate impacts
are on water availability on crop
productivity and now on rangeland
productivity so to cover kind of grazing
livestock based livelihoods
and those are the main kind of factors
that influence uh the attractiveness of
places in the future so you'll see
basically the model moving people out of
areas that wear water availability goes
down and into areas where water
availability goes up
we've tried to
capture things like conflict in the
model but it's very imperfect at this
stage in the sense that
you cannot predict conflict into the
future so you kind of have to assume
like certain areas that had conflict in
the past will be less attractive because
of conflict in the future but we know
that that's not really how it works
where like the conflict may be moving
somewhere else
so that's a limitation and it also um
obviously doesn't
um account so much I think it does
account to a certain extent for existing
Mobility patterns
um but it obviously it cannot capture
all the intricacies of like family ties
and ethnic ties and you know like that
drive a lot of people's decisions for
where they're going to go
so there's actually data current
contemporary data on how people already
believe within some of these locations
that you can draw on as an input into
the model well the problem is that I
think you you you could do that for
these more smaller scale agent-based
models so if you wanted to actually
really say like okay we're in Accra
Ghana and we want to understand like How
might people be moving into Accra I
think you could start like really
looking at what are the existing
migration patterns and how do we build a
model based on that but for these kind
of like models that are trying to do
this at scale it's very difficult to
have I mean you don't have that data at
scale right like so that's the
incompatibility if you will like that
you need data that is available across
different locations to have these kind
of
Global models or whole of continent
models
but as also I think it's important to
have the different stages of the
research as well with the modeling that
takes down to the other parts as well
with both the
the the qualitative part and the
consultation but also then yeah why it's
important you might say it and why are
you like you've done the work why you go
to the National level local level of
course that sounds like but it is really
important to understand the real drivers
of this to talk to those people having
the test experience as well to really
get a sense of yeah a decision to move
is not easy and it's usually not as
as you cannot summarize it as in one
point driving it it's usually complex
and a few few points going into it
um so thank you for this presentation
and I have also like a question related
to the the assumptions that you have so
every model the result of a model
depends on the assumption that you're
taking so if you can tell us a little
bit more about how you're Gathering that
information and what challenges you have
encountered as well
um in order to build in that and how to
calibrate basically also with things
that you see
in the future and the other question
that I have is that so you have these
ranges of probabilities of what this the
forecast that the the results that you
can see here are you building with that
as well like different scenarios
depending on how extreme you can see or
certain parameters that go after some
levels as well in order to have the
recommendation
are all the work that you are going to
be working with the different
governments
I'm not sure I understood the second
part of your question
um on the first part
um so we didn't build the model
um we work with colleagues so
um are on the 100 City University of New
York and Columbia University and they
built this model originally for the
world bank's Groundswell reports
and then upgraded it for our purposes so
we built in they use different
population data for this model they used
more layers of climate information so
they put in a flood mask for example
they added this conflict mask so there
were different more factors layered in
than that was the case for the
Groundswell model
and the calibration as far as I know was
done basically picking again countries
for which data is available and looking
at in the past how have certain things
like drought or flooding affected
migration and use that to kind of
predict the future
um
so yeah there's lots of kind of things
where you know you you
say okay again like what you know what
we find for Cameroon and Ghana and five
other countries we're going to now use
across other countries right where you
can always say well how accurate is that
as an as an assumption to be made
um
on the second part yeah
what I was saying is that so you have a
path of the more likely scenario but you
also are showing the results like a
probability of this event happen so what
I'm saying is that
given that more extreme event are
happening more often are you able as
well to build like different scenarios
okay if I don't know if
temperature rises by this much which
exactly form five or whatever figure you
you want to put there
this is more likely to be the effect so
you will be more like on the Tails of
the distribution and basically also
given the as I said work with the
government in terms of uh
we are trying to adapt to the different
events yeah
yeah so we are for this exercise that
four scenarios and actually in the
report we mainly focused on the kind of
pessimistic scenario
um in the sense that the optimistic
scenario was really we stay within 1.5
you know we're meeting the Paris targets
and
we said that is not the most likely
outcome right so we actually have mostly
in the report focused on the more
pessimistic scenario but then said you
know even with the more
kind of negative climate trajectory you
can see that the development trajectory
matters right like because there's
basically these two variables how are
you doing on development and how are you
doing on climate and even if climate is
not going well if the emissions
reductions are not happening fast
whether you make progress on development
makes a big difference in terms of the
vulnerability of your population and so
that's been the main message for African
governments basically from the report to
say like you know you can not do so much
about the emissions reductions there's
not so much in your power I mean you can
obviously Advocate and so on but at the
end of the day there's not so much again
to decarbonize in a lot of these
countries
but you can do quite a lot about the
development well quite a lot you can do
something about the development
trajectory
um and that's where uh that's where the
kind of
difference can be made in terms of
outcomes
so I mean I think you said you said
under the
Rocky Road scenario which is the worst
case scenario
migration actually is slightly lower
than in a more optimistic scenario which
is an eye-opening point and I think you
said it's because that people won't even
have the resources that they need in
order to migrate which means they're
trapped which means things are much
worse in location
interpreting that right yeah
and I think from this Caribbean model
this comes out even more starkly that
you'll basically just have a share of
the population that's going to be very
poor
not very likely to be moving especially
not across International borders
and that's maybe the people that you
should be most concerned about
um but yeah I mean we found that and
again this is our interpretation but I
think it is consistent also with some of
the You Know Field research findings and
what we know from the existing migration
research that especially going longer
distance International is expensive you
need contacts you need money
um and so
if people are moving they're moving
short distances if they're not if they
don't have those contacts and those
resources
they're not moving like across the
continent let alone to like Europe or
anywhere
so Elisa is asking first she wants to
thank you for the very interesting
presentation and she would like to
inquire if you also provide support to
policy makers regarding the social
economic and cultural integration of
migrants and does your organization
offer data about the regions and
condition of origin while also working
to raise awareness within the host
community
additionally do you have do you suggest
best practices for social inclusion
hopefully at some point I know I mean um
so I think the the interesting piece
about this hot spots mapping is that it
gives you both end of the story
um it doesn't allow you actually to make
connections between
uh
places so you can't really say okay
these people are coming from here and
they're going to there
it can only tell you well here's where
we think population will Decline and
here's where we think it will increase
but I do think that this analysis of
where population will increase is is
very interesting and valuable and I've
come from quite a bit of work with the
city and local authorities
and so I think we do see that as a very
important constituency of our effort so
looking at you know hey what what do
they already know because there's been a
lot of lessons learned from large-scale
displacement crisis whether they're
climate related or not like Lima Peru
taking in a million Venezuelans or you
know so there is a lot of I think things
that cities have already done and know
how to do and it's not always well
publicized
um but then also yes we do I think
ultimately would like to get to a point
where through this knowledge Hub
um
we we start collecting more information
on the solutions right like so far a lot
of the climate Mobility research has
been focused on the drivers like
understanding how important is climate
as a driver of people's movement where
will people leave where will they go I
think increasingly you want to shift the
research agenda also towards this
question of well what is what what can
be done in response and what what do we
know about things that are working
and I think that that also covers a part
that was not really part of this
presentation which comes to our Flagship
program Mr hopefully is going to address
some part of that that's going to focus
on green skills climate literacy water
solution and data so of course it ties
into the research that's presented here
but I think that there's ambition and
there's also interest and also already
some efforts going on through these
programs that's going to address
hopefully both the host communities and
people staying here as Tony mentioned
people being trapped or or not having
the the opportunity to decide where
they're going to move so hopefully those
parts will cover
social inclusion to some degree because
I know that was part of the question but
definitely the economic part when it
comes to Green skills
we have 15 minutes more but uh and I
have one question and then other people
if they want so um
what uh yeah I would like to know as
well how much you include the risk
into the
into your model and basically in
what I'm thinking is about people
insurance against these events I
understand that probably in developing
countries and not everybody is
um
able to ensure against
climate change but I guess working with
the governments actually in order to
sort of
incorporate the the risk of living in
these areas that you have identified as
being more prone to to this yeah
problems
yeah
I think this goes a bit to what we
discussed like how do we get done to
more kind of decision support
um I mean I do think we know that social
protection for example can be
both a means for people to stay in
places but it can also be a means for
people to move but depending on the
context so I think in terms of what is a
appropriate response
I guess
we want to make sure that people have
agency and a certain degree of
well-being whether they stay or move
right so so the um the intervention I
think whether it's Risk insurance or
it's social protection
um I think if we're kind of trying to
measure success by whether we manage to
make people stay or have them move might
be tricky and I think that's another
question that is kind of on the table as
we're advocating for climate Mobility to
become part of adaptation programming
adaptation policy how do we measure
success
um what does that look like
but yeah to your to your point I think
it's definitely one of our action agenda
items is around this like you know how
do you just basically ensure that people
can make decisions about moving a with
having information about climate risk so
this goes through climate literacy but
also access to Climate Services
um but also how do they have kind of the
resources that they would need to be
able to make those decisions so and in a
lot of cases that will mean
social protection or
access to climate Risk insurance like
things that will actually allow them to
have
a certain degree of agency in the
context of disasters and climate impacts
and I think that covers some part of it
the social part of the economic part I
think they're also the part about
culture and Heritage that we also tried
to cover a bit that is not covered by
those factors when it comes
uh yeah for certain communities
something that that's something that I
just want to put a pin in that we are
trying to address as well that I know
what's your question Theresa but I think
that that goes beyond this question was
asked online and this like it's not only
the social and economic but also
the cultural heritage of community and
the community yeah hopefully it comes
that in in the third phase of things to
really see what we can do for
communities there
thank you thank you so much this is so
interesting
um and so many questions
um and uh could you clarify please when
when uh when you speak about songs like
where people plan to migrate like green
zones mostly uh the others better off
somehow in any parameters are like as a
result of climate change or they are
just less worse off and uh are there any
areas which are better off somehow uh
like physically environmentally as a
result of climate change in the
continent or maybe economically because
of the migration and labor somehow or
the whole continent with the divorce of
just a different face
that's a really good question I think
you have both so you have actually
situations where people are basically
just going from one bad situation to
maybe a less bad situation so for
example if you're at the results for
Mozambique show quite a lot of movement
into the coastal areas that are we know
very vulnerable but because the
conditions in the rural Hinterlands are
predicted to get worse and so the model
is moving people to the coast where you
have bigger cities but that doesn't mean
they're out of a risky environment but
then you also have I think certain areas
of the continent that could actually see
conditions improve like where crop
yields are forecast to improve due to
more rainfall
um
so so you have a little bit of both but
I would say
very often especially this movement into
urban areas is not necessarily a
movement into much better conditions
especially if urbanization isn't handled
well right and that goes to your point
around like Economic Opportunity I think
a lot depends on
um
again like forward planning and
investment right to see how can
um how can that be absorbed like we know
people will be moving into these areas
can you already put infrastructure in
place now that will make it easier
afterwards to build up housing for
example if you already have the
um
basic infrastructure in place then it's
easier rather than trying to retrofit
informal settlements that have already
sprung up things like that
um
but yeah it's uh it's not necessarily A
Rosy pic but like there's many places
where you're like oh these will be
climate Havens yeah
and I think you shouldn't yeah not be
fooled by the colors of green and red it
doesn't mean that it's it's green it's
green light or red it's very simplistic
to say but it doesn't cover that part I
think no
just one one quick question I know we're
running against time but I'm curious
um about your strategies around kind of
evidence uptake and
um sort of uh sensitization and
mobilization of these tools and this
information obviously it'll be as good
as whoever uses it for some of the
planning and decision making and it
strikes me as it's potentially a wide
array of different policy makers who
could Avail themselves of this
information so you know I'm curious how
you're you're working in collaboration
with national sub-national actors to to
kind of promote uptake of this
information and to promote uptake of the
tools that will be developed
yeah
yeah so I think right now we see it
Mandy and David can speak to that more
but I think we see it mainly as an
awareness raising tool
um and also as a tool again to inform
this kind of global level more advocacy
conversations bringing people together
starting this conversation putting the
topic on the agenda
when it comes to the more policy
formulation then it really becomes this
work that I outlined with like Uganda
where it's like okay let's work with
this government let's see you know how
concretely can we help you to make this
part of your planning practice part of
your policies
um and how ultimately you know we where
we want to get to is like help Uganda
unlock money from the green climate fund
to have specific projects in place right
like that's where we would like to get
to with these countries
um
and so I think we have kind of probably
different strategies with different
audiences
um
and also still working on our strategy
so that's also true but yeah
no I think yeah I think you covered it
so I think it's also part of then the
clams literacy part that tells about
climate literacy but then we also have
the climate Mobility literacy part which
is yeah you can see the numbers there on
climate literacy I don't think we're
close to that on the climate Mobility
trying to merge these agendas and have a
conversation about it here I don't think
that's a necessarily a conversation in
the U.S or in Europe where I'm from but
less so that or even something that
that's both on the national sub-regional
but also in the yeah looking at copy
talked about copper before I think it's
starting to make its way in there we
said we did a pavilion it doesn't mean
that it's front and center negotiations
but there are different things we're
trying to do there to bring it up
then yeah we can talk more about we're
trying to do these Flagship problems as
well and also working with youths to see
like what does this information mean to
you and what what is what would it be
helpful to take it and do it I think
that that's something that especially
youth that I work with are kind of keen
to figure out with their peers in terms
of right now we know this how do we go
and and and and take action on this of
course there's more formal processes
with governments that we're working at
the national level but there are also
these constituency-based Arts that you
mentioned yeah other types of
organizations there are a lot of Youth
that have a lot of interest in seeing
this is happening about in their
communities
I think that where this idea of
ecosystem building comes in like I I
mean just looking at the conversation
here in the US and how that's evolving
around like you know climate
displacement climate
um
refugees
um I think you will in each context need
kind of people that figure out what the
narrative needs to look like locally
um because I think in most contexts it's
not an easy conversation right to talk
to people about where they might have to
abandon their homes and we've heard
quite a few stories of people going back
to places that they were relocated from
right like where the government said
okay
bra is one example we heard the same in
Uganda where like the government said
okay you have keep having landslides
we're going to move you out of this area
but this area is very fertile for
farming so people will be coming back
there and Bearer they come back because
they do fishing right and if you
relocate them to the interior that's
just not where their livelihood is so I
think in practice a lot of these things
are hard to do
and governments are often not super Keen
to take this on as a as a conversation
with their people and so I think that's
something where I don't think we can
necessarily give
I think we can give governments tools
but to figure out like how do we talk
about this in a way that resonates with
our community in a way that resonates
with our people I think that's the work
that they will have to do and where we
will also learn right what what what
does that
look like
and I think that that's also a little
bit about lettuce here because we talked
to Tony last year trying to figure out
how to talk about these things so I
think that yeah there are people here
that are trying to figure out for the us
and we're trying to we've determined
we're determined to figure it out to
some degree across the world when it
comes to Cloud Mobility
I think we're working more Hands-On
David mentioned the rising Nations
initiative which is also a regional
effort but is slightly differently
organized and there it's a much more
Hands-On effort with one particular
country which is tuvalu that is facing
um submersion this century and so there
it's much more Hands-On thinking about
this like how can the government go
about formulating a strategy with the
with the people like with involvement of
the people what does that look like how
do we on the one hand keep fighting
for our right to adapt and to stay while
also making preparations for the
eventuality that maybe people would have
to move and then what David mentioned
what does that mean for culture and
Heritage of people how do you preserve
that what does it mean for their
statehood and their sovereignty so
that's a kind of like
special project if you will
um that we're working on and that is
getting a little bit more directly into
these kinds of questions
yeah but part two being the pilot but
now also like it is for Pacific halls in
general but I think it's kind of clear
also when you start talking about this
Rising Nations initiative that a lot of
the things are things that people are
thinking about across the world but
especially in the other Pacific
countries so even though yeah the
resignations initiative is spearheaded
by tuvalu Marshall Islands and kiribas
there are like as soon as you start
talking about it there are other Pacific
countries that say oh we might not face
a merchant but these questions of
culture and Heritage applies to us as
well and I feel like when I talk to
our colleagues in Africa that those also
things that are starting to come out
more and more so even if it doesn't it's
not the existential threats to the same
degree
their questions their their questions
that are going to remain
yeah I think the urgency the poetic
urgency is different
well with that thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]